hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to terror lab now this
started off very strange
I sometimes explore the deepest reaches
of the internet to find bizarre and
interesting games press Enter to reset
oh okay cool what did that do I have no
idea flashbang rani good god man what
did i do I can't see okay well this is
dark and spooky so anyway like I said
again that does not help anybody it just
blinds me
I'm flash banging myself time to recover
memory you know I've not a goddamn idea
what the hell just happened
this game is bizarre I cannot see a
thing I can't seem to do I have a
flashlight I thought that just because I
had a flashbang meant that I wouldn't
ever have a flashlight okay so let's try
to meander without dieing I oh hey how's
it going there oh dude come on
Wow it's gonna be one of those games
I'm gonna call you Chad because you're
just as douchey as a Chad would be not
offending anybody god dammit stop that
that's not music stop it so it said
something about it said something about
a radar I don't know I wasn't exactly I
wasn't exactly reading the description
or the instructions or anything that I
was supposed to be doing because -
flabbergasted which is the only word
that I can use in this situation I was
too flabbergasted with what the hell was
happening to me anyway as being
subjected to senses that I've never
experienced before in my life I can
smell the rust on the walls it's as bad
times all around anyway let's try not to
die again you're harshing my buzz
[ __ ] Chad all right Chad you may need
to have a talk about the dynamics oh
yeah I have a flashbang should I use the
flashbang when he comes up running up to
me probably cuz Chad wants to party all
day long we have an exam in 24 hours
Chad Chad that gets you Chad I wake you
up oh god I can't see oh he's still
there
hush I don't know why I expected Chad to
just disappear on me like of course he
was gonna come a-runnin around the
corner well what am i what am I supposed
to do am I just supposed to play keep
away from Chad is he getting a little
frisky with me probably
Chad Oh Chad you hear me grunting off in
the distance that would normally get you
running my way if you know what I mean I
guess I got to keep up the generator
which is back in the other room but I
don't know where Chad went Chad come on
man I didn't mean it I mean just because
you're the worst frat
row that I've ever been a part of I'm
not saying that I'm a part of you we're
not we're not like two halves of the
whole whole and I don't want to talk
about holes when I'm around you Chad but
you know though it was just an
experimental time in college Chad I mean
I I've moved on
Chad no Chad go away I feel like this
game could easily replace the character
with Shrek and put this and make this a
really really hilarious Shrek simulator
just Sam it's entirely possible I guess
I gotta wait until the memory recovers
but that's gonna take for freaking
forever I'm gonna jump out this window
Chad is that what you want Chad come on
Chad show your true feelings we used to
be closer than this Chad what happened
to us Chad what happened to the
emotional connection that we had on a
deeper bro level Chad we were just
having a bromance and you you made it
all weird Chad yeah you just wanted it
to be physical Chad don't remind me of
our Antarctic Cruise Chad just because
we were on a cruise together doesn't
mean that we were meant to be together
Chad goddamn it Chad you make me feel
things that I don't want to feel you
make me think about times that I don't
want to think about anymore all of our
bro moments or bromans it was good you
know it was brewed that's bro words for
good we had a great time growing out in
the woods that's woods in grosbeak
hunting bro deer
or staying of Ironside the time we went
dancing Chad let it go Chad that was so
long ago I've moved on yeah
press ENTER to stop audio system I don't
know what that means
oh hey Chad it's so silent when you're
creeping up to me Chad remember when you
used to talk to me you know we used to
talk through our problem Chad just cuz I
dumped you I bro dumped you doesn't mean
that you gotta be all cramping my style
bro my bro style my Bryl yeah I called
Brian up we used to have good times
jadon used to have good times back in
our early party days and I know I know
Stacy got in between both of us
literally and figuratively but you got
to let some things go you some things
sorry go back into my college lift when
I think of you I'm sorry Chad I just
thought you were around the corner
didn't know that you were gonna be not
sneaking up on me like you usually do
Chad you resolved you were always a
rogue Chad a broke a bro rogue you know
what it is you're [ __ ] Chad Chad you
have a nice ass but stop showing it to
me you're not tempted me at all
our bro monkey our brung key
Chad you remember back in college when
we used to play spank the brung II went
a lot like that just over here the flash
flash rash oh there you can't even move
Chad you can't do nothing Chad what are
you gonna do Chad you're frozen like a
statue
afro statue brought you another pokemons
broke Eman shut up I'm broken I'm broken
inside I don't see any way to win Chad I
don't see any way to win what we have
back what we had back I don't see
anything Chad lousy anything but the sad
this you've left in my heart my bro
heart my Bart don't make fun of me Chad
don't mock me you know that I'm
sensitive you know where I'm sensitive
hey that's the last time I'll flash you
willingly
oh hey you got a little closer than I
thought
just like baking chocolate why can't I
quit I quit youichi i thought this was a
door I thought I was making a dramatic
entrance exit there sorry Chad had to do
it had to do Chad aggressiveness now
Chad we're gonna talk about your bro
gressive miss why don't you try to be
more bro progressive progressive and
learn what being men is really about
which is getting to touch with your bro
feelings your breathing's Chad are you
coming from Chad oh hi Chad please you
know I can't keep this up Chad oh god
the Branka stop spanking my bunkie okay
so anyway I'm done with here I think
I've I think I've revealed a lot of very
disturbing personality flaws about
myself
and Maya deep-seated issues with Chad so
I'm gonna end this here before it even
gets started so thank you everybody so
much for watching
god dammit I have no idea what just
happened but this is a game and if you
want to play this game I'll put the link
down in the description below I don't
even remember where I got it I just saw
that it was on my list so thank you so
much for watching and as always I'll see
you and Chad in the next video bye
surprised me so much geez get out of my
life